[Music]
[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
here on sky news coming up on today's
programme a multi-billion dollar effort
to tackle climate change in the u.s is
passed by republicans and democrats
deforestation in brazil rises by 22
in 12 months with more than 13 000
square kilometers of rainforest lost
and egypt is urged to lead the fight
against climate change as the royals end
their tour of duty
[Music]
hello there welcome to the uk's only
daily climate news show where we track
the changes happening to our world right
now and we challenge those coming up
with the solutions our top story tonight
it is the biggest environmental
investment in u.s history 555
billion u.s dollars part of the trillion
dollar infrastructure bill and today
it's finally been passed in the united
states house of representatives the
climate portion of the bill includes
incentives for shifting to clean energy
for consumers coastal restoration and
forest management and was a big part of
joe biden's build-back better initiative
at cop 26 in glasgow its next step
making it through a divided senate
before it can reach the president's desk
but for now it is a moment of
celebration on the capital
the years are 220
the nays are 213.
the buildback better bill is passed
[Applause]
let's go straight to washington join our
correspondent joe pike joe it is a huge
amount of money isn't it what sort of
impact will it have
well not quite yet because you say
jonathan it doesn't need to get through
the senate and it's likely to be watered
down currently the price tag is
2 trillion with half a trillion being
spent on the climate if it does get
through the senate uh that we will see
investment in trying to get the economy
to move away from fossil fuels and move
in industries like the automotive sector
towards electrifying uh cars electric
cars but it is a real challenge uh
coming up next for joe biden and his
democrat colleagues because the senate
is split 50 50. he does need one
particular senator on board joe manchin
a democrat democrat of west virginia who
is uh leaning to the center he's not
he's not one of the sort of progressives
he is more centrist i suppose blair
wright is maybe how you describe it in
the uk terms well it is of course
entirely different and he is facing uh
an election uh in the next year or so he
wants to uh keep his job and he
represents coal country therefore i'm
sure he'll want to
water down certainly some of the climate
element of this two trillion dollar
package but certainly joe biden and
nancy pelosi are taking the win today
this is one of the two big pieces of
legislation that are at the heart of joe
biden's presidency one of them on
infrastructure has already been passed
this is the second more complex more
difficult one it's not just about the
climate but about a social welfare and
the health system too but it's got
through a very important step jonathan
and all eyes on the senate now to see
what happens there
okay we'll wait and see joe thank you
very much uh joe pike in washington
there well let's take a look at the
dated dashboard shall we here is the
power mix in great britain at the moment
gas makes up 43.9 coal is on 2.7
today renewables 26 and nuclear
13.9 percent the number down here at the
bottom shows the global co2 emissions
right now and as you can see that number
ticking up all the time well to counter
the release of those emissions it is
essential that the world's rainforests
are protected because they act as a
carbon sink absorbing carbon dioxide but
today new research shows that the rate
of deforestation in the brazilian amazon
is at its highest in 15 years
[Music]
it's a huge challenge we need to address
it we're
first thing we
recognize that we have a problem in
terms of deforestation and we are
acting in order to solve this problem
[Music]
now are we as a developing country we
need resources investment we are g20
member country as you said but we still
have our difficulties
[Music]
let's take a look at some of today's
other climate news and an indian power
company will start building a coal mine
in botswana in
2022 which could produce 4.5 million
tons of coal every year it comes as
botswana announced renewable energy in
the country could increase to 18 from 2
over the next 20 years
43 beaches in south korea are suffering
from serious coastal erosion according
to a survey by the oceans and fisheries
ministry that's up from 12 beaches in
2018.
rolls royce's battery-powered plane has
smashed the fastest all-electric flight
world record the spirit of innovation
aircraft reached a top speed of 345
miles an hour over three kilometers
rolls royce chief executive warren east
called the flight a milestone towards
making jet zero a reality
now the prince of wales and duchess of
cornwall have ended their tour of egypt
it was their first visit in 15 years and
it comes of course less than 12 months
before the country hosts cop 27. while
the queen rests in windsor castle prince
charles has taken on a leading royal
role the couple met artists filmmakers
and the founder of banlastic egypt
driving a ban on single-use plastic well
the royals were visiting alexandria one
of the city's vulnerable to rising sea
levels caused by the climate crisis the
princes used the tour of egypt to really
keep up momentum created by cop 26
urging world leaders to take action in
the fight against climate change and
protect some of the treasured wonders of
the world sky's royal correspondent
rhiannon mills has been traveling with
them and sent this report about the
future king and his environmental
activism
putting on a good performance is a big
part of these tours prince charles and
camilla nothing but willing as they
arrived in alexandria and it has been a
week where there has been more focus
especially on him after the queen pulled
out of remembrance sunday because she
was unwell
although 100 years is a fair old age
i could only say like shakespeare that
to me fair friend you never can be old
and look forward to the next century of
our friendship
what testimony
now the most senior of the family to
travel he may not have the title yet but
still receives the same welcome as any
other head of state
regarded by the uk government as a man
that leaders will listen to
royal tours are a tried and tested model
for soft diplomacy but there's no doubt
that for some time he's been doing it
differently from his mother
a man who has a forthright determination
to bring different faiths together and
the most strident some would say not
entirely politically neutral views on
addressing the climate crisis
prince charles is going to have to walk
that very fine line between representing
the queen but also wanting to assert
himself and his own position
um and as he gets closer to the throne
um the challenge to walk that tightrope
becomes ever greater
he was in his element surrounded by
tradition at the biblioteca a revival of
the ancient great library of alexandria
what a beautiful day some would argue a
new era would deserve a new approach a
palace source once told me that when
you're monarch you can be but as air you
have to do and if the prince of wales
didn't do anything then he would be
criticized of course there are those who
think in the past that he has
overstepped the mark but he has
addressed that by saying that in the
future he will not be a meddling monarch
for all of the show not everything has
gone to plan a visit to hms queen
elizabeth cancelled and questions about
his charity rumbling on back home
over the years he has developed very
thick skin and one thing never in doubt
he's always known what is expected
rhiannon mills sky news in alexandria
well we'll be discussing more on prince
charles's campaign to tackle climate
change and the role of high-profile
figures after the break i'll be joined
from glasgow by laurie young a climate
activist and environmental scientist and
by michael jacobs professor of political
economy at sheffield university join us
all in a couple of minutes
so the work one of the works here behind
me these are fingerprint details molds
sculpted from the surface
of this one from the man of glass one of
the most iconic glaciers in europe if
not the world
and i travel up to the glacier i take a
mold from the surface
of the ice spend the night on the
glacier hearing it carving cracking the
sounds are phenomenal
and i take a fingerprint mold i take it
back to the workshops the studio and
then here they're casting bronze and
then once they're set in bronze they
become that permanent reminder
of our engagement with
our landscape climate change climate
crisis you know our engagement with our
landscape
is
one of the most significant well the
most significant you know
aspect to the work that i'm creating
like i say these pieces okay they're
there to set as a reminder on how we
engage with our landscape and they act a
certain extent as like a memento mori
you know no longer do we have a skull on
sat on our desk to give us and remind us
that you know death is written into the
contract of life
these work now as glaciers instead
because every day you walk past you can
see them here
it gives you that reminder and subtle
nod
to you know
that your engagement is really important
the idea is that i'm capturing this
transient powerful force
which etches its way through the
mountains that we now inhabit
and
acts as this permanent reminder for us
as to as to you know how we deal with
our beautiful mountain beautiful
landscape
and it's kind of here and now it's it's
tranquil it's still and it will last
forever like on the back of each one of
the sculptures is the gps coordinates
from where
this actual piece comes from from the
glacier which is now melted eroded and
lost so in 50 years 100 years time
200 years time you can you can type in
the coordinates you know you can see
it'll do its thing and you'll see that
the glacier is no longer there however
you're left with this permanent reminder
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line they are dying here
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us get ready
instructing you to stay at home
i believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
[Music]
a band of rain will move south on
saturday heralding a change to much
colder conditions much of england and
wales will be dry and mild if rather
cloudy the rain band will move
southwards across scotland northern
ireland and the republic reaching wales
in the midlands by saturday evening
sunny spells and scattered showers will
follow from the north but it will turn
noticeably colder
air pollution levels are expected to
remain low across the whole of the uk
and ireland on saturday between 1 and 3
on the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello again welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
climate activist and environmental
scientist lori young and michael jacobs
professor of political economy at
sheffield university now news that
deforestation is at record levels in the
brazilian amazon will come as no
surprise of course to environmentalists
in that country the administration of
jail bolsonaro has been widely
criticized for allowing and even
encouraging illegal logging but brazil
signed a pledge in glasgow to stop
deforestation by 2030. so how can he be
held to his promise and how can leaders
more widely be held accountable to their
promises on climate action let's find
out what our guests think michael
starting with you why don't we just have
a look at that pledge that leaders made
at cop on deforestation that we can
bring it to you now this is what they
said uh we commit to working
collectively to halt and reverse forest
loss and land degradation by
2030
but how on earth do we get leaders of
places like brazil to stick to those
pledges
well of course we don't if by we you
mean people in every other country other
than brazil brazil brazilians hate it
including brazilian environmentalists
when the rest of the world talks about
our rainforest they say no this is our
rainforest it's in brazil it's also in
several other countries
in latin america
and the only way that bolsonaro the
president of brazil who has shown
absolutely no interest in stopping
deforestation uh although he signed that
statement the only way to get him to do
so is brazilian political pressure from
within the country there are there is
quite a big environmental movement uh in
brazil and of course they have an
election next year and the uh principal
opposition candidate the former
president president the former president
lula
has said that he will run on a uh on a
platform of stopping uh or slowing down
deforestation eventually stopping it so
this is all about brazilian politics
what's interesting of course is that he
did sign that statement president
bolsonaro and if international
agreements were really useless he
wouldn't have bothered doing so so he
clearly feels some pressure from outside
and that is the pressure that
international agreements like the one
that was achieved in glasgow can achieve
they can put some pressure on but really
accountability is ultimately
what politicians get from their own
domestic constituencies yeah yeah we'll
get laura's thoughts on this uh very
shortly but quickly michael what about
sanctions international sanctions could
they not work
um it's very unlikely uh uh with the
current state of international politics
that sanctions would be applied we've
tried that before actually when we in
the first international climate
agreement the kyoto protocol signed in
1997 there was a sanctions regime for
countries that didn't meet their targets
they were going to be required to have
stronger targets next time round but it
didn't work countries that didn't meet
their targets like canada just withdrew
from the kyoto protocol and so it no
longer applied to them so when it came
to the paris climate agreement in 2015
that uh regime of sanctions was
abandoned so now all we have is peer
pressure the pressure that being part of
the international community and signing
an agreement has on any every country
and you might think that's very weak and
at one level it is but another level the
paris climate agreement told countries
to come back five years later with
stronger commitments and they all did so
including brazil
so it does have some impact even though
there is no legal sanction yeah well
those figures laura are really
distressing today aren't they
deforestation in brazil up 22
since last year its highest level since
2006. let's have a look at what
greenpeace had to say today we can show
you that uh if anyone believed
bolsonaro's governments empty promises
at cop the truth is in those numbers
what about people power law that's what
i want to talk to you about because
you're a climate activist how important
is that in making a difference making
leaders
accountable so important it's one of the
really
important things we can do as
individuals to talk to our local
government representatives for me up
here in glasgow that's my msp my mp all
the way up and to really try and push
from the bottom i love that analogy of
kind of peer pressure from around the
world as well because although the
amazon is vital it's the lungs of the
earth and we all need to be doing a bit
to protecting it we can set a global
standard for forestry and that's
something that we can look at here
within the uk as well we can ask our
elected leaders how are we leading the
way with deforestation bringing that
back and also our forestation putting
more force in and that's something we
can talk to our local representatives
about to push the change to hopefully
make our
leaders of the uk influence global
leaders as well
other people that can influence of
course are celebrities high profile
figures laura i know you were up in
glasgow i don't know if you got a chance
to meet leonardo dicaprio when you were
there do you welcome uh people like him
those sort of people with with huge star
power coming in and getting involved in
uh in climate action
i think it's great the more the merrier
who are inside the climate movement you
know any person can be a climb activist
and we need people from all walks of
life to do climate activism in their own
way there was a lot of fuss around some
celebrities coming to cop26 and i guess
in one breath i would say that it did
take some air time away from really
important voices who weren't necessarily
represented at this top young people
indigenous people people from
marginalized communities and so i think
there's definitely a role for
celebrities to play in the climate
movement it might not just necessarily
be front and center taking up time at
these conferences but i would encourage
more celebrities to get on board and to
talk about this but also to really walk
the walk when it comes to climate action
i think one of the biggest criticisms
for celebrities jumping on board is the
hypocrisy and it's about how we can
encourage them to do better individually
but also use their sphere of influence
to encourage business and government to
come along with us as well yeah good
point we've been following prince
charles in egypt over the last few days
michael british royals obviously
traditionally don't get involved in
politics but are the rules different
when it comes to climate change do you
think
well yes and no um so prince charles has
been very active on environmental issues
in general and climate change in
particular for quite a few years and by
and large he's not had the kinds of
criticism uh for doing that that he has
in some of the other areas where he's
intervened like
like
architecture
and planning where he's been more
criticized and that is because in
general environmental concern is
cross-party um i think
as a somebody who works in a politics
department i know that many people who
work on constitutional matters are
concerned about this yes climate change
and environment is a generally popular
clause but in principle when you have a
hereditary monarch or in this case the
heir to the monarch the point is that
they don't get involved in politics and
you know one of the things we always say
about the queen is how remarkable it is
that she's been on the throne for all
this time and we really don't know what
her political views are because she has
kept them to herself and the fact that
we have a new uh there to the throne who
will presumably be monarch fairly soon
whom we know his views about many issues
of which this is just one i think
worries a lot of people
who study the constitutional question
but on climate he has been he's been a
force of good i don't think he's the
greatest influencer on tick tock but he
has been important in convening business
leaders political leaders and others to
discuss this and so in that sense he has
played a positive role yeah and he said
he won't be a meddling uh monarch so he
may tone things down a bit when uh when
he finally becomes king and just 10
seconds law really do you think prince
william do you think young people listen
to him when he talks about green issues
more so than other people so that's a
good thing
all right great uh really good speaking
to you both thank you very much indeed
michael jacobs laurie young always good
to talk to you have a good weekend and
don't forget you can download and listen
to climatecast wherever you get your
podcast from this week ashlander nag
gets two very different views on the
glasgow climate agreement from george
monbiot and sepi golzari monroe and that
is everything from us for today but do
stay tuned because coming up next
18 year old
kyle rittenhouse found not guilty on all
counts and acquitted for the shooting of
three men
that's the latest in a couple of minutes
[Music]
you